another large group of refugees arrives
at the give gelia transit camp in
Macedonia loudspeaker announcements in
Arabic provides some guidance but the
long march to safety means the new
arrivals are often confused exhausted
and disoriented and in one significant
way they're different last year most of
the refugees were single men now the
majority are women and children they
make up almost sixty percent of the new
arrivals the UN's Children's Fund UNICEF
says that this group of refugees are far
more vulnerable and that Europe must do
all it can to ensure their protection in
give gaelia and in many other camps
UNICEF has set up child and family
protection hubs in a bid to prevent
human trafficking inside there's a
nursery atmosphere for just a few hours
an island of normality and for those who
need them a pair of new boots
with the men outside UNICEF staff look
for signs of trafficking a bruise
perhaps or a particularly introverted
child the organization wants national
governments to share that responsibility
you know it's a responsibility not at
UNICEF to take care of the children in a
new country it's a responsibility of the
country itself so we want to see that
the country's a beef or boost up their
their their systems to protect children
on the walls pictures depicting
childhood memories some good some more
traumatic several show the treacherous
journey across the Aegean Sea couched in
the optimism of the Rising Sun